l'apiculteur et ses abeilles se
connaissent bien se respecte l'enfumoir
par exemple sert à les calmer et
assurent également la sécurité des deux
parties et ce qui explique la présence
d'un essaim dans son jardin celis image
une partie des abeilles quittent la
ruche et s'en va s'installer ailleurs
la colonie va se scinder en deux parties
c'est à dire l'ancien ul par antiga avec
deux tiers les abeilles de la planète et
si d'aventuré on doit faire face à un
essaim dit sauvage dans son jardin
surtout ne pas les déranger garder son
calme est la seule solution
quand vous il faut garder votre calme
c'est le rêve contre le mas le phénomène
qui s'est passé il faut pas qu'on tombe
dans la psychose je pense que le quidam
qui se retrouver face à un nid
d'abeilles a été surpris il a dû
paniquer l'abbé guy m'a piqué l'intrus
quand elle va lâcher le dal va émettre
une aumône et c'est tant mieux elle
s'appelle la substance dans l'âme donc
ça va alerter les autres et elles vont
tout vous pouvez le sud et puis ne pas
essayer non plus de les chasser
en faisant de grands mouvements avec les
bras il faut savoir que la bei elle a
des yeux en face et c'est comme si on
était dans une pièce où il y at il
toutes pièces et est tapissé le miroir
donc le geste commentaires sont à
répéter à ce moment là soit sans
agresser donc elle va vous attaquer et
dire que quelques surpiqué et si cette
personne est allergique
si elle a des difficultés à respirer il
faut tout de suite l'emmener chez un
médecin
et puis quand on repère un i5 dans son
jardin dans un arbre le mieux est de
faire appel à un apiculteur